another mass shooting rocks colorado joe
biden continues to lock kids in cages
while keeping the border open
and democrats aren't done yet calling
for the end of the filibuster in adding
state
i'm bench bureau this is the bench
bureau show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben which is as good a time as i need to
remind you that you actually should get
express vpn because here is the reality
big tech they are not out to protect
your best interest they're out to
monetize
your data and by the way to use that
data against you
in the case that they don't like what
you are doing at some point turning on
incognito or private mode in chrome or
safari that's actually not enough
it doesn't matter how often you clear
that browsing history your isp internet
service provider can see every single
website you've ever visited they can
sell your data to advertisers which is
why i use expressvpn to keep my online
data secure
and private expressvpn makes sure your
isp and third-party trackers can't see
your online activity and location
it does that by rerouting your
connection through a secure encrypted
server
in fact expressvpn protects all your
data regardless whether you use
incognito mode
expressvpn has you covered with easy to
use apps for computers and mobile
devices so you can use the internet with
confidence all you have to do
tap one button now you are protected
expressvpn is also the fastest and most
trusted vpn on the market which is why
they are rated the number one vpn by
cnet and wired so
protect your online activity today with
the vpn i trust to keep
me private visit expressvpn.com ben you
get an extra three months free with that
one year package that's expressvpn.com
pendle learn more it's super easy you
click one button on your phone now
you're good to go it's super simple go
check them out right now expressvpn.com
ben to learn more alrighty so big news
of the day is another
horrific mass shooting at this time in
colorado where 10 people were killed
at a colorado supermarket according to
the associated press a shooting at a
colorado supermarket killed 10 people on
monday including a police officer who
was the first to respond to the scene
according to authorities police arrested
a suspect they didn't reveal his name
or any details about the shooting at an
evening news conference where boulder
police chief
maris harold fought back tears
investigators had just begun sorting
through evidence and witness interviews
and didn't have details on a motive for
the shooting
at the king supers store in boulder
which is about 25 miles northwest of
denver home to the university of
colorado according to boulder county
district attorney
michael doherty he said this is a
tragedy and a nightmare for boulder
county these were people going about
their day doing their shopping i promise
the victims and the people of the state
of colorado we will
secure justice the attack was according
to the associated press
the seventh mass killing this year in
the united states following the march
16th shooting that left eight people
dead at three atlanta area
area massage businesses according to a
database compiled by the associated
press usa today and northwestern
university and of course it all depends
on how you define mass shooting
because some definitions are like three
people or more some definitions
are five people or more it follows a
lull in mass killings during the
pandemic in 2020 which had the smallest
number of such attacks in more than a
decade which is mainly because people
were locked inside their houses so
people couldn't congregate which means
it was more difficult to pull off
a mass shooting this database tracks
mass killings defined as four or more
dead
not including the shooter one of the
reasons by the way that a lot of these
statistical databases like to separate
off mass shootings with four or more
dead
is because if they include three or more
dead then the numbers rise dramatically
and the racial composition of the
shooters goes
dramatically differently because it
turns out that a lot of gangland
shootings that involve
people who are killing two three people
and so the numbers change pretty
radically you'll notice that mass
shootings are always the excuse for gun
control but the deadly violence that
happens in chicago every single weekend
that is never the excuse
for gun control because again this plays
into the broader media narrative which
is that the big problem in america
is white supremacy and america's systems
of violence
the slain officer was identified as eric
talley 51 who'd been with boulder police
since 2010 according to herald he went
to the store after a call about shots
fired someone carrying a rifle
he was by all accounts one of the
outstanding officers of the boulder
police department his life was cut too
short already said
of tally identities of the other nine
victims were not disclosed monday night
as police were still notifying
their family members matthew kirsch
acting u.s attorney for colorado pledged
the full weight of federal law
enforcement
to support the investigation officers
did escort a shirtless man with blood
running down his leg out of the store in
handcuffs
authorities would not say if he was in
fact the suspect
officials have not said whether the
suspect is the person who was taken from
the shooting scenes at foothills
hospital
in boulder in the hospital is not
releasing any more information dean
schiller told the ap
he had just left the supermarket when he
heard gunshots and saw three people
lying face down two in the parking lot
one near the doorway he said he couldn't
tell
if they were breathing there was also
video live streamed on youtube which
showed one person on the floor inside
the store and two more outside on the
ground and you can stay on you can hear
gunshots
at the beginning of the video at one
point authorities said over the
loudspeaker the building was surrounded
and you need to surrender
sarah moonshadow told the denver post
two shots rang out just after she and
her son
nicholas edwards had finished buying
strawberries she said she told her son
to get down
and then we just ran it's obviously just
another
horrific mass shooting and the media
typically
in these situations responds by
suggesting of course
that people who don't agree with their
basic policy prescriptions are somehow
unsympathetic
to the victims in these sorts of
situations because
you know that the next political move
here forever and always will be a
federal call for gun control
joe biden has been looking for an excuse
to push gun control for a little while
here now
he's been talking about gun control
consistently for the last 10 15 years
he used to be somebody who's a little
looser on gun control now he is somebody
who's much tighter on gun control he's
been pushing for an assault weapons ban
i'll of the 1994 assault weapons ban
that really had no impact on mass
shootings in the united states he's been
looking for that
for quite a while so this will be used
politically as a
as a hook in order to push forward
the gun control agenda and the media are
going to foster this by suggesting of
course that if you don't agree with joe
biden's agenda it's because you don't
care
about the people who were killed it's a
cheap political trick that is played
during every tragedy
that if you don't agree with my policy
prescription it's because you don't care
about
the people who have died or the people
who've been victimized in any
particular way you can see the media
already ramping up
for this right that if you say that the
gun control
measures that are likely to be pushed by
the federal government are
extraordinarily unlikely to prevent mass
shootings
in fact virtually every gun control
policy that's been pushed by the federal
government has had no
impact on mass shootings the number of
guns in circulation in the united states
has risen dramatically over the course
of the last 15 to 20 years
the number of people who have been
killed in mass shootings year on year
has actually been going down
but that does not matter to the to the
folks
who who push gun control and so their
idea is you are unsympathetic to victims
this has been a thing ever since i told
piers morgan not to do it on cnn
the the reality is that you can be
deeply sympathetic to people who have
been harmed in any sort of crime
and still recognize that that
bad policy does not solve the problem
okay but you can see
the media already sending the predicate
so here on cnn was one of the reporters
saying that this is just the way america
is this is just it's unique to america
this is how america is now
realistically speaking america does have
more
absolute numbers of mass shootings than
other countries but there are mass
shootings in australia they've been mass
shootings in norway if you were to look
at the number of deaths per million from
mass shootings it's actually higher in
some civilized countries than it is in
the united states
nonetheless again the predicate here is
that america is unique
that this problem is easily solved by a
simple policy change which of course it
is not
and the media are going to suggest that
if you oppose that policy change it's
because you don't care about what just
happened in boulder colorado here with
cnn
jumping on that within probably an hour
of the shooting breaking
the larger story here that may not be
addressed today but is a
is one that we have to address in light
of what happened uh in atlanta which is
are we
facing a spring and summer of uh you
know matt's casualty events
uh as we come out as people congregate
uh and that is something that the
biden white house will have to address
as well juliette how can that be how can
it be that after a year
of basic quarantine in the country the
first thing we do
as americans is go back to mass
shootings i mean how can that be
okay so again the the level of of
incredulity i believe it's alice in
camerata over on cnn
the level of incredulity there the the
notion that you are
how can it be that we as americans are
going we as americans aren't doing
anything
i didn't shoot anyone today did you i
didn't engage in a mass shooting
in fact as of yesterday as far as i'm
aware there were some 330 million
americans who didn't
engage in a mass shooting it's not as
though everybody went out in the streets
and started shooting guns in the air and
then turned the guns on their fellow
citizens
there are 300 million guns in the united
states there are over 100 million long
guns in the united states
okay virtually none of them were used in
a mass shooting yesterday
but there was one used by somebody who
was evil we don't know his name yet we
don't know his motive yet
okay so we have no insight into why this
we have no insight into how the gun was
obtained we just don't have any
information as of yet that has not
stopped the media from immediately
setting
the emotional groundwork for a gun
control push and again the emotional
groundwork is that this is the norm in
america this is what's regular and most
americans are fine with it most
americans just turn a blind eye casey
hunt
at nbc news pushing the same sort of
idea she's the capital hill
correspondent she tweeted out we're all
emotionally exhausted after the last
year we've lost so much and so many but
i refuse to let exhaustion help
normalize 10 people getting shot and
killed as they go about their daily
lives for any or no reason
we have a moral imperative to be better
than this i don't even know what that
last part means
a moral imperative to be better than
what nobody is saying
that what happened in colorado is decent
good or should be something that we
ignore
and what who is saying that better than
what did you engage in a mass shooting
yesterday i didn't okay
this notion that all americans are
somehow okay or blase about 10 fellow
americans being shot to death in a
supermarket
including a police officer and some
other blase about that
that we can't just go back to our normal
i don't believe that casey hunt is more
sympathetic than you are more than i am
i don't believe that casey hunt
is a a deeper wellspring of
emotion than you are or than other
normal americans are i think all
americans
are rightly outraged at the act of evil
that we saw yesterday in boulder
colorado
but again the media are setting the
groundwork and the groundwork is that
when joe biden comes out and makes an
emotional pitch for gun control if you
don't believe that that gun control
is is truly well calibrated
toward reducing risk and preserving
rights then this means
that you just don't care right you're
not better than this in the words of
casey hunt
right you're you you shouldn't normalize
no nobody's normalizing anything
but this is the same game that our media
play and it really is kind of an
emotionally manipulative game
that if you don't agree with what they
want it means you're a bad person that
is the subtle argument that is being
made here it's not a particularly subtle
argument
in reality some people are less subtle
even than that mary l trump
who is famous only because her last name
is trump and has made a bajillion
dollars off of writing
a book about how much she doesn't like
donald trump so mary l trump tweeted out
the nra is a terrorist organization and
should be treated as such
do we have any evidence that this
particular person was an
nra member or that the nra fostered his
behavior or that the nra trained him for
this behavior
by the way what exactly is that
suggestion if the nra's a terrorist
organization then presumably we should
round up all the members and put them in
gitmo
if the nra is a terrorist organization
what we're going to go around does joe
biden have the capacity to just drone
american citizens
who happen to believe in the second
amendment
so little of this is rooted in anything
remotely resembling a policy debate
that if you want to make a case for
specific
pieces of legislation that would
mitigate
mass shootings or shootings at all well
actually preserving americans
fundamental right to defend themselves
and defend their property and defend
their rights
then bring it forth but this is the big
barack obama used to admit this all the
time he used to say
sure the le legislation we're not
bringing forward on gun control wouldn't
stop this shooting
but it might stop other shootings might
okay well if it wouldn't stop the
shooting then why are you talking about
this piece of legislation on the back of
this particular
act of evil they recognize the game
before it's being played because i
promise you this is going to be the
narrative over the course of the next
couple of weeks as joe biden immediately
shifts
into gun control mode he's immediately
going to shift into gun control mode the
media are going to shift along with him
because they don't want to talk about
what's happening on the border because
that of course is a biden fostered
crisis and so they're immediately going
to shift with joe biden into gun control
talk
and the implication is going to be those
evil obstructionist republicans
if only they would just go along with
the gun control agenda
then all of this would stop and if they
don't go along with it it's because they
wish to normalize in the words of casey
hunt what just happened in colorado
again no one is normalizing acts of evil
that is not something that any fellow
american is doing and if you are
imputing to fellow americans that they
literally don't care about people
getting shot in a supermarket in
colorado we shouldn't share the same
country
if you truly believe that your fellow
americans
do not care about innocents being gunned
down in a supermarket then you're living
next to people who are evil
and you shouldn't be sharing a town with
them you shouldn't be sharing a church
with them you shouldn't be sharing a
country with them
but that is the underlying emotional
play that is being made here by your
delightful
mainstream media alrighty in just a
second we're gonna get to the situation
on the border which continues to just
marinate and get worse
day after day first spring is springing
it is a good time to remember to tidy up
and get your life in order why not start
by protecting your family
with life insurance today policy genius
can help you compare top insurers in one
place and say 50
or more once you find your best option
the policy genius team will set up your
new policy for you and answer any
questions you have along the way
here's how you can get started first
head on over to policygenius.com
in a minute you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes to
find your best price
policy genius makes it easy to compare
policies from as little as 15
a month you might even be eligible to
skip the in-person medical exam
since their licensed agents work for you
not the insurance company there is zero
hassle if you hit any speed bumps during
the application process
policy genius will take care of
everything for you soup to nuts that
kind of service
has earned policy genius a five-star
rating across thousands of reviews
on trustpilot and google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius the
comparison tool handling of paperwork
unbiased advice
totally free to use you got family
relying on you god forbid something
should happen
you got to make sure they are taken care
of so while you're tidying up around the
house this spring get that life
insurance organized as well say 50
or more by comparing quotes head on over
to policygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important
to get it right okay so meanwhile the
situation on the border continues
to get worse and worse and this is
driven explicitly at this point by joe
biden's terrible policy
according to axios the biden
administration kept a trump-era policy
known as title 42
as a tool to quickly turn back adults
and families who illegally cross the
southern border
but according to new department of
homeland security data leaked to axios
it has not been used at all for families
so trump had a policy if you show up on
the border we
force you to remain in mexico while we
adjudicate your case you can apply for
asylum in mexico
you can't cross the border and just
disappear into the interior that was
title 42
but dhs now says that if you arrive as a
family they're not going to do that in
fact
the data shows an average of just 13 of
nearly 13
000 family members attempting to cross
the u.s mexico border will return to
mexico
between march 14th and march 21st using
the public health order
which essentially says the u.s can close
the border to non-essential travel
because of the covet virus
it's a sign of how the administration is
struggling to keep up with the migration
surge and has recently been hamstrung by
mexico's inability to take in more
families the u.s would otherwise expel
well actually it is not a sign of how
the administration is struggling to keep
up with migration surge it's a sign of
how they are unwilling to keep up with
the migration surge
they're saying let everybody in in the
same administration that tells you
that florida is is terrible because it's
wide open and coveted's going to spread
and we're all going to die and keep
masking up
they're not even using the coronavirus
pandemic to reject people at the border
that we have not tested for covet
that's how ridiculous and incoherent
this administration's policy is
the other 87 percent won't remain in the
us indefinitely according to axios but
they will be allowed into the u.s to go
through immigration proceedings which
means they will stay in the us
indefinitely
proceedings can take years the dhs
spokesperson said well you know one week
of stats doesn't reflect the full
picture
our policy remains that families are
expelled and in situation where
expulsion is not possible
they are placed into removal proceedings
white house press secretary john sackey
says the process of deporting those
families sometimes
takes a minute to ensure there's proper
transportation and steps in place to do
that no what's happening right now
is that you guys have decided that
you're just going to let a ton of people
in
and joe biden has incentivized all of
this it is perfectly clear
at this point the good news though is
that
kamala harris is happy about it
apparently so kamala harris was asked
whether she's going to go visit the
border she's not by the way
kamala harris apparently is now going to
visit florida she tweeted out yesterday
help is here she put out a tweet help is
here she wasn't landing at the border
she was landing in florida guess what
vice president we don't need you here
in fact the great success of the state
of florida is because we have explicitly
rejected
everything you could have possibly
recommended you're from california the
state that i rejected
because they went entirely the wrong
direction do not come here and bring
your crappy policy here
the state of florida voted against joe
biden and kamala harris for a reason
and it's because they reject the kind of
help is here help us here says kamala
harris
yes we desperately we desperately in
florida need the help
of kamala harris an incompetent senator
who couldn't get zero percent in a
california primary before she was
plucked out of obscurity
thanks to the fact that joe biden wanted
a black female for his vice president
we need her help desperately so she
arrives in florida
and uh and she then is asked about
whether she's going to head down to the
border
and she breaks out the joker laugh which
makes perfect sense because this is
super funny stuff guys
do you plan to visit the border
not today
but um i have before and i'm sure i will
again
where is the batman
it's she's got the worst i mean that's a
bad nervous dick that is it a lot of
people have nervous texts
that is a bad one she's asked a
difficult question and she starts
cackling
you know oh my god you wonder why the
democratic party needs to wheel around a
not fully sentient not fully alive human
as presidents of the united states
because all that stands between kamala
harris
a terrible awkward horrific politician
in the presidency
is that old man that's why they have to
just keep pretending that everything is
fine
in biden land because here is the thing
kamala harris as the face of this policy
looks very very different not because of
race or gender but just because she's
terrible at this than
joe biden does okay in any case the
situation on the border again continues
to be bad
the media were barred from the from
these migrant facilities where we now
have a multiple of people
who are being kept and housed but
footage
did leak from inside the migrant
facilities project veritas got a hold
of some of the footage here's what that
looked like project veritas has obtained
never before seen i'm sorry photographs
of what it actually
looks like inside this facility
children's sleeping inches
showing people wrapped up in what looks
like metal foil
laying on the ground their face is
covered
why won't the administration be honest
about this why won't they
show you these images we have now
obtained these photos
inside this facility now these photos
are very very grim
project veritas has also learned these
photographs were taken
in the last few days okay so
if you actually could see the photos
this is why you should subscribe so you
can see the photos
if you actually see the photos they're
astonishing i mean honestly
it looks like a bunch of people wrapped
in aluminum foils
lying down inches from one another
inches you want to talk about a coved
super spreader
event this would be what that looks like
okay and they are being put
don't worry those are not kids in cages
guys this is happy fun time camp with
joe biden
it's all great over there everything's
fine according to the biden
administration not a crisis
and also everybody should keep coming
but i'll show they should stay away
because it's awkward right now but also
the media shouldn't be allowed in
because if they see those pictures then
it might be bad for the administration
even cnn
finally catching on they say um yeah it
turns out that we now have migrant
children who are essentially staying in
jail cells here with cnn
finally doing its job you have more kids
coming into u.s custody but
just not enough space to put them in
shelter so that means that these kids
are staying in border patrol facility
for prolonged periods of time and those
are facilities that are not intended for
them they
look like jail like conditions like
prison cells with concrete walls and
concrete
benches and these kids are spending more
than the three-day limit than they're
supposed to
according to federal law so the
administration racing here
to find enough space for these kids that
is suitable for them
okay yeah are they racing are they
racing though because i feel like
they're not racing so much
and i feel like if they wanted to make
sure that kids were not
along the border they would reject
families at the border which apparently
they are not doing
these turns out families generally have
kids but they're not rejecting the
families they've fostered this border
crisis and every single person knows it
in fact nbc's steve gutierrez said that
migrants say they are now being
encouraged by the biden administration
we have spoken with several migrants
over the last several days andrea both
on this side of the border
and over in mexico and matamoros mexico
that said that they were
encouraged by the change in
administration many of them didn't know
the specifics
of president biden's border policies but
what they did know
is that he was not president trump and
some of them
did feel that now would be the time to
come to the border
so actually that's gabe gutierrez sorry
about the first name scrub gabe
gutierrez the nbc news correspondent at
the border
fully saying that these migrants are
arriving and they are saying they're
doing so because of biden
but don't worry according to the
administration it's not because of biden
everything is totally fine now the media
are finally beginning to catch on to all
of this
the media are beginning to pretend to
care so the media have decided that they
don't like the fact that there is now
lack of border access
which is good i'm glad that they have
woken up to the problem that is the lack
of transparency
inside the biden administration so here
are some of the members of the media
beginning to
have questions for the body
administration about why you won't let
us in here's katie tour
from nbc news saying that the lack of
border access is
somewhat disturbing well yeah it is
divided administration kept talking
about transparency and we're not getting
any transparency here
with what is happening at the border
that we have to get those images uh from
a congressman
who won't say where he got those images
um it is very frustrating for not just
journalists but for the american public
who want to know what's going on
inside those facilities those disturbing
images
okay so katie turtle calling it out jake
tapper of cnn now calling it out
today we saw this rare look inside these
facilities since the biden
administration has not granted
news media access to the facility citing
coveted restrictions despite the
president's promise and his inaugural
address
to always level with you blocking access
to the news media is not
leveling with the american people mr
president yeah they're not leveling with
the american people they're refusing to
release statistics
and by the way who are you going to
believe the administration or your own
eyes
jen sackey said literally yesterday that
as these pictures were emerging of these
kids sleeping directly next to
each other and adults by the way
sleeping directly next to each other in
large numbers
inside what looked like essentially
plastic bubbles she said don't worry
we're following all the cdc guidelines
oh are you it looks it looks super safe
over there
these kids are tested if they need to be
quarantined they are quarantined
we also follow cdc guidelines to ensure
that they are kept
safe one of the reasons that it took us
some time to
uh have some of these facilities or some
of the shelters
open to larger groups of kids is because
we wanted to follow those cdc
guidelines but where else in the country
would it be okay
to have 400 people
in a space for 260 during the pandemic
well again peter are we're closely
following the cdc guidelines
uh no you are not you really really
really are not
you have said that kids cannot be in
schools
okay kids can't be in schools if they
are three feet or less apart
okay but you are keeping these kids
inches from one another and it's totally
fine
which suggests this is not really about
covenant on the one hand and also they
just don't want to do anything about the
immigration problem
according to the washington post over
the last three weeks the average number
of teenagers and children crossing into
the united states without parents
has topped 550 per day border officials
are on pace to take in more than 17 000
miners this month which would be
an all-time high this is obviously a
crisis
biden has a has had a markedly different
approach than his predecessors to an
influx of homeland
that homeland security secretary
alejandro marcus said was on pace to be
the largest in the last
20 years 20 years so far they're just
adding capacity to shelters and other
facilities to absorb the influx
declining to implement policies that
would send minors back because the
administration considers the policies
morally unacceptable
which means they want this to happen
that is their goal
which suggests that it's all about the
agenda it's all about the political
agenda
just keep letting illegal immigrants
into the country and everything
will be fine and by the way this is the
same administration that said if you
come after january 1st we're not going
to simply amnesty you does anyone
believe that including the illegal
immigrants are crossing the border
of course not meanwhile joe biden's
plans grow ever more grandiose
apparently
joe biden wants to blow three trillion
more dollars
three trillion more dollars so we're
already inflating
the currency beyond all measure because
sooner or later somebody has to pay for
this crap we just paid for two trillion
dollars of spending
for no reason at all because we are
already coming out of the pandemic
now biden wants to spend another three
trillion dollars this time
to quote boost the economy reduce carbon
emissions and narrow economic inequality
according to the new york times this is
going to start with a giant
infrastructure plan
that might be financed in part through
tax increases on corporations and the
rich
yeah that's not going to have any impact
you're gonna take all the corporations
that
have to rehire everybody right now and
you're going to tax them
in order to pay for roads that largely
should be done through the state and
local level
after months of internal debate biden's
advisors are expected to present the
spending proposal to the president and
congressional leaders this week
as well as being an outreach to industry
and labor groups industry and labor
groups are the key here
when you wonder why biden wants to spend
trillions of dollars on this stuff it's
because he wants to
quote create good union jobs right the
goal is to pay off big labor because the
most corrupt open bargain in american
politics
is that our democratic friends they pay
off the unions
the unions then take that money and pour
it back into campaigns so that democrats
can be elected to pay off the unions
it's the most open
corruption in american politics and it's
been going on for decades
administration officials caution the
details remain in flux but the enormous
scope of the proposal
highlights the aggressive approach the
biden administration wants to take as it
tries to harness the power of the
federal government to make the economy
more equitable
address climate change and improve
american manufacturing and high-tech
tech
high technology industries in an
escalating battle with china
i always love when the new york times
quote-unquote reporting reports they
want to make the economy more equitable
what the hell does that mean
equitable is a mush word it is a word
that means whatever the biden
administration wants it to mean what it
really means
is that they don't care about growth
rates they care about redistribution of
income
and they say they're going to address
climate change question what policy here
is calibrated to addressing climate
change
if the united states were to go carbon
neutral right now it would lower
the carbon it would lower the climate by
estimates
about 0.2 degrees celsius by the end of
the century
so what in the world is he talking about
the 1.9 trillion
economic aid package biden signed into
law this month includes money to help
vulnerable people and businesses survive
the pandemic downturn but it does little
to advance the longer term economic
agenda
oh um so that's a lie the economic
agenda is
completely tied in to the billions of
hundreds of billions of dollars in that
package that are designed to creating a
new welfare net
for people without any requirements as
to their behavior
according to seth hanlon senior fellow
at the center for american progress
president biden's plan represents a
stunning shift in priorities addressing
many of the nation's most pressing
challenges the plan is super
wide-ranging reflecting the fact we've
under-invested in so many areas
under invested in so many areas we are
spending four trillion dollars a year
before the pandemic last year we spent
something like seven trillion dollars
and that doesn't count the fed spending
which was
another several trillion dollars and now
we've already got the four trillion
dollar budget that's gonna pass this
year
plus another two trillion dollar package
and you want to add another three
trillion on top of that so you're
talking about nine ten trillion dollars
blown into the economy by the biden
administration this year do you think
that's not gonna lead to runaway
inflation
get ready gang it's coming over the next
couple of years right now
we can survive it because the economy
has been artificially depressed but what
happens when the prices
increase and because we owe so much
money we still have to have these
dollars in circulation
what happens then stagflation is a real
thing
it has happened in multiple economies
and pretending that what goes up does
not come down
cannot be the hallmark of your economic
policy if you actually care about growth
which apparently they don't
right now the white house officials say
they want to
focus on the infrastructure stuff that
plan would spend heavily on clean energy
deployment
and the development of other high growth
industries of the future like 5g
telecommunications it includes money for
rural raw
broadband advanced training for millions
of workers by the way these advanced
training programs i wish they were
successful i wish you were just as easy
for somebody going out
losing a job to get trained for another
job and stick them in a government
program it doesn't work that way these
programs are not particularly successful
one million affordable and energy
efficient housing units
um i don't think those are going to be
affordable not for the american people
if by affordable you mean that we're
going to subsidize government housing
in a time when the economy is going to
be booming then
good luck with that officials have
discussed offsetting some or all of the
infrastructure spending by raising taxes
on corporations
including increasing the 21 corporate
income tax rate and a variety of
measures to force multinational
corporations to pay more tax
in the united states on income they earn
abroad
so they're going to punish corporations
for success
even as they attempt to rehire americans
who've been put out of the work by the
pandemic
sounds perfect we're at 3.5 unemployment
before the pandemic
and your goal is now to reach is now to
quote unquote build back better by
completely shifting the basis of the
united states economy that had been at
historic highs
before the pandemic don't worry it'll
all be fine
so they're just going to keep blowing
out the spending no matter what they
want to raise the top marginal tax rate
to almost 40
from 37 percent they want to
they want to change the tax rates and by
the way it's going to bleed down into
lower tax brackets
according to the new york times one
question is how to apply mr biden's
campaign promise that no one earning
less than 400 000
a year would pay more in federal taxes
under the plan currently the top
marginal income tax rate starts at just
about five hundred thousand bucks for
individuals
and about six hundred thousand dollars
for couples biden proposed raising that
rate during the campaign
but here's the problem they've debated
whether to lower the income threshold
for the top marginal tax rate to tax all
individual income
above 400 grand at 40 in order to raise
more revenue for spending plans and
they're going to raise a bunch of taxes
that do impact people making less money
than that because when you tax
corporations you're inherently taxing a
bunch of people who make less than 400
a year but don't worry it doesn't stop
there the democrats are now pushing
forward on their plans to kill the
filibuster
which would in essence mean ramming
through every radical policy proposal
you could imagine we'll get to that in
just
one second first if you want to get
healthy and stay healthy you need to
know how you make decisions so my wife
has been working really hard with noom
right she loves new because it helps her
change her habits
every single day i've used new myself is
why i look so felt
and wonderful okay new doesn't just help
you lose weight it helps you know why
you lose weight what sort of habits you
need to change in order to lose at the
weight based in science built by
psychologists noob doesn't give you
rules instead
teaches you how to think so you can
accomplish your personal health goal
stick with them long term and get
healthy
for good based in psychology noon
teaches you why you make the decisions
you do
and gives you the tools to replace your
habits with healthier habits noom's
cognitive behavioral approach means
you're not just improving your health
you're gaining the knowledge and habits
you need to stay healthy in the first
place everybody's busy so newman doesn't
demand
a lot of your time they ask for only 10
minutes a day newman is designed by
psychologists there's no scientific
jargon
over 80 percent of numerous finish the
program over 60 have stuck with their
goals for at least one year it is a
super successful excellent program
there's a science to getting healthier
it is called noom sign up for your trial
today at noomnoom.com
shapiro learn how to get healthy with
noom sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.com
shapiro if you're ready to learn how to
live healthier sign up for noon today at
noom.com shapiro alrighty in just one
second we're gonna get to the democrats
attempting to kill
the filibuster first if you haven't
heard by now but
honestly if you listen to this show you
would have heard candace owens has a
brand new talk show with us exclusively
at dailywire.com the full show might be
available to daily wire members only but
candice is also a podcast you can listen
to on apple spotify anywhere else
you get your podcast the canvas podcast
features several breakout segments from
the full length show
including interviews panel discussions
and her advice corner the podcast is so
good it reached number two
on the apple podcast chart after the
first episode so if you need some
candace owens in your podcast feed
look no further head on over to apple
podcast or spotify subscribe today
be sure to leave a five star review if
you like what you hear you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
so just as it is with gun control if you
disagree with the left it means that you
are in some way
unsympathetic or evil well when it comes
to every element of the democratic
agenda that is basically the pitch so
now the new pitch by democrats is we
need to get rid of the filibuster and we
need to make
washington dc a state okay so we've got
hillary clinton out there saying it's
time to dump the legislative
filibuster um no no it's not
but now the case by democrats is
basically that the legislative
filibuster is a racist tool which is
weird because barack obama used it
repeatedly when he was a senator the
democrats used it repeatedly to shut
down for example a police reform bill
from the black senator tim scott from
south carolina who happens to be a
republican
so filibusters are only only racist
apparently when republicans use them
here is secretary clinton
making the case i think we need to bring
back a real legislative process
if you thought you had to actually stand
up and vote on something
you'd actually work to get an amendment
to change it
as opposed to saying i don't even have
to think about it i'm just going to show
up and
and i'm i'm going to be part of a
filibuster that doesn't
inspire cooperation it just keeps people
in their separate camps so i think it's
going to
take a little bit of change in order to
get to where people have to work
together and surprisingly in my own mind
i think
you know getting rid of the filibuster
will actually have that result that's
the dumbest thing i've ever heard
so now she's saying that getting rid of
the filibuster will create
bipartisanship
in what way seriously in what way the
democrats just passed a two trillion
dollar package with no republican
support
none okay and there and they did that
because
they didn't have to have a filibuster
right it was filibuster proof
they could just do it with a simple
majority they could do with 50 votes
plus kamala harris
so what in the world is she talking
about the case that democrats usually
make is that the filibuster is racist
even though it has been a
a piece of procedure that has been in
place and used by both parties for
centuries at this point
nonetheless erwin tremorinsky is now
calling the professor
formerly of usc he is now calling for
vice president kamala harris to simply
declare the filibuster unconstitutional
he says in 1957 vice president richard
nixon is sitting as presiding officer of
the senate issued two advisory opinions
holding that a crucial provision of the
senate's filibuster rule requiring
two-thirds vote to amend it was
unconstitutional
nixon's constitutional determination was
reaffirmed by subsequent vps
hubert humphrey and nelson rockefeller
in fact it was this ruling that allowed
both the democratic controlled senate in
and the republican-controlled senate in
2017 by simple majority vote to
eliminate filibusters for all executive
and judicial nominees
harris possesses the same exact power
which essentially establishes a 60-vote
super-majority rule the filibuster she
could say it's unconstitutional because
it denies
states equal suffrage in the senate in
violation of article 5 of the
constitution which is
absurd okay the senate can come up with
its own procedures
the notion that the senate is that these
states are are denied
equal suffrage because you need a super
majority to pass things you could bring
the same exact complaint
against the other areas requiring super
majority consent including for example
impeachment right it takes two-thirds of
the senate in order to green light and
impeachment
is that denying in some way is the
constitution itself unconstitutional
everyone agrees the text of the
constitution does not allow for simply
giving california more senators than
wyoming says erwin trumarinsky
nor can the senate's lack of
representative fairness be cured by
adopting internal senate voting rules
but that doesn't mean the senate has
authority to create even more unfairness
than already exists
in fact article 1 of the constitution
doesn't allow a broad 60 vote super
majority rule
okay again this is ridiculous the senate
has the ability to make its own rules
now would it be a good idea for kamala
harris to simply overthrow the
filibuster in a time of high political
polarization and division in the united
states would be about the dumbest thing
she could do
if she did that i will tell you what the
predictable result of all of this is
going to be as democrats
surge forth with a more and more radical
program with fewer and fewer people
supporting it
what this is going to look like as
opposed to a bipartisan compromise
what this is going to look like is
states beginning to say
you passed it now enforce it if you
really want to pass it
you can try to enforce it but we're not
helping you not one iota
we're just going to become sanctuary
states where people actually still have
constitutionally guaranteed freedoms
doesn't mean we're gonna arm use armed
opposition to stop the feds from doing
things
it does mean that you are going to have
to enforce this sucker yourself that is
what you're going to start getting
very very quickly meanwhile the
democrats really want to get rid of the
filibuster because
number one they want to completely
destroy the system of voting in the
united states by violating by the way
the constitution
so they want to get rid of the
filibuster so they can violate the
constitution by federalizing all voting
procedures which were not delegated to
the federal government
under the constitution of the united
states h.r 1 is a crap show
it is a horribly written bill that
dramatically increases the possibility
of voter fraud and dramatically
undermines
the ability of anybody to believe in the
voting system of the united states and
this is coming from somebody who doesn't
believe that the last election was
decided by voter fraud and regularity
you want to make sure that every future
election is in doubt make sure you pass
hr one
it's not just that now the democrats are
pushing to simply add
new states so notice the pattern here
irwin tremorinsky is now claiming
that we should get rid of the filibuster
because it's unfair
because it treats states unequally and
they need to do that
so they can add states so they can
completely overthrow the bargain that
the states currently have
by adding with a simple majority vote
states like the district of columbia so
democrats want to add dc as a state
because they want two additional
senators
it is not the the claims that are being
made by the democrats of course are that
if you oppose dc statehood this is
because
you are of course racist ayanna presley
the ringo starr
of the squad she came out she said dc
statehood is a racial issue of course
because everything's a racial issue
every single thing here she was
there have been only two black elected
governors in the history of this country
massachusetts had one of them deval
patrick now in more than 230 years
only two black governors i'm going to
make a plain
dc statehood is a racial justice
issue and racism kills and i don't just
mean police brutality
and hate crimes and food apartheid
systems and transportation deserts
and unequal access to health care i mean
all of that too
but racism kills our democracy right
okay so it is racist
not to make dc a state because we need
to appoint people
to governorships based on race that's
the case she's making
racism is bad because we need black
people to be governors
now um i'd seem to remember that the
vice president of the united states
is a black woman and i seem to remember
that the president of the united states
was a black man for eight
years and the attorney general of the
united states was black
and the secretaries of homeland security
and the secretary of the uh the current
secretary of defense is black
but according to ayanna pressley we need
to
make dc states that that will have a
black governor her assumption of course
is that dc will have a black governor
because there's a heavy black population
in dc
which again is kind of racist the notion
that black people only vote for black
people
by the way not really true because again
black people did not vote for a black
person in the primaries they over joe
biden in the democratic primaries
but in any case you know why dc is not a
racial issue
because it has long been held since like
the foundation of the country that the
district of columbia
should not be under the auspices of any
state because if you have a state that
means the seat of the federal government
is now in hocked to the states
that's not a racial issue it can't be a
racial issue because at the time
no black people could vote okay that at
the foundations of this country
black americans were stopped from voting
by racist policy
so the notion that the federal district
of columbia
was prevented from being a state because
white people were afraid of black people
gaining power is an absurdity
historically speaking and it also
happens to contravene the explicitly
stated intent of making the federal
district of columbia federal
in the first place federalist 43 james
madison fully explains
why the district of columbia is a
federal district
he says if it were not
then the federal government would then
be in hock to the states
it would create a dependence on the
members of the general government on the
state comprehending the seat of
government
for protection in the exercise of their
duty might bring on the national
councils an imputation of awe or
influence
equally dishonorable to the government
and to dissatisfactory to the other
members of the confederacy
in other words dc would be seen to be
running the federal government
as opposed to the federal government
being dc this consideration has the more
weight as the gradual accumulation of
public improvements at the stationary
residence of the government would be
both too great a public pledge to be
left in the hands of a single state
and create so many obstacles to a
removal of the government as still
further to abridge its necessary
independence
the extent of the federal district is
sufficiently circumscribed to satisfy
to satisfy every jealousy of an opposite
nature again this goes all the way back
to the foundation of the country the
notion that this is racially based is
ridiculous on this face but
again it's not about any of that it's
about america's bad unless you give me
what i want her she did it to lead says
it explicitly
she says america is an authoritarian
system unless dc is a state
it's a this kind of language about the
country that
allows for immigrants to the united
states to become members of congress
regularly it is it is quite an
astonishing thing i mean rashida talib
is one of the great beneficiaries of
america's systems of freedom and
meritocracy
and yet here she is saying that
america's racist because dc isn't the
state
in opposing d.c statehood which is
overwhelmingly supported by the people
of washington
these representatives and their dark
money backers over the heritage
foundation that's right
are telling over 700 000 americans to
sit down
shut up and enjoy this authoritarian
system implemented by a bunch of elites
who thought it was okay
to enslave people for their selfless
monetary gain
hundreds of years ago it is shameful
that anyone would claim to support
democracy and freedom
and oppose statehood you can't even
support democracy and freedom in opposed
dc statehood
and that's what she thinks of the
american founders all they were were
slaveholders
it's amazing stuff there from refutedly
but this is the democratic party the
democratic party is not going to stop
anytime soon
they believe they are on the ascent and
they are they're on the rise they're in
the ascendancy
they're going to the future of the
united states is an authoritarian left
boot stamping on your face forever
that's what this is and they're going to
do so by killing the filibuster they're
going to do so by changing the voting
rules they're going to do so by
incentivizing illegal immigration and
they're going to do so by cowing you
into silence by
leveraging the power that they have
institutionally in order to shut you up
that is the future of the country over
the next few years there's only one
thing you can do to stop that and that
is
don't shut up and don't acquiesce to
their ridiculous suggestion that if you
disagree with them
this makes you somehow morally deficient
which is an absurdity on its face
because i'll tell you what this agenda
is morally deficient alrighty
we will be back here later today with an
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
coming up soon the matt wall show airing
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
on the mat wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show